if you're just joining us rudy giuliani
is sweating his
face off explaining to us why trump
really won the election
again inspectors every state
almost every approve this is thrown away
gone for eternity is this a skit the
only thing left is to have been a dead
person
that could have been not filled out
probably wait he's saying there was a
dead person
in the envelope rudy's about to have
actual
drops of sweat coming off of his brow i
mean is this a normal amount i don't
know how hot it is in the room but this
something seems
very wrong here i'll be in the lawsuit
that comes out duty's melting
arizona is a ca as a state that we're
looking at very very carefully
strongly looking at it i would say we're
probably i assume
she's working if she's working for them
i'd like to read them all to you but i
don't have the time you should have had
the time managed to go look for that
that's your job like it's my job to
defend
the president i don't represent the
president it's lane
michigan wisconsin is is he bleeding did
you see
is he bleeding from his ear what on
earth was that
to find out this is that hair dye
is to look at the lawsuits in order to
do it it looks like blood
but in the material oh my god it's
everywhere ten
thousand at least and we're getting he's
gotta get off the stage
and there are other aspects of this
fraud on the morning of november
someone's got to get him a napkin they
were going to count
the these this new kind of balance
i've never seen anything like this what
on earth it's getting onto his shirt now
she again and it was con
any jury would accept if they heard this
evidence
that somebody had this plan this is
insane maybe that was always the plan
it looks like sap from an oak tree or a
maple tree it looks like someone's
making syrup
the city described that to you oh my god
it's all over his
face he's gonna need a towel
dealing with jill evidence i don't know
guys it's sounding like trump one
isn't it based on this
if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points
if you can sample trump saying massive
dumps and me talking about it in a song
please do it
which is just
in areas where there's tremendous
amounts of water where the water
rushes out to sea because you could ever
handle it people are flushing toilets 10
times 15 times
as opposed to once dumps dumps
dumpsters
what is going on here it's just beyond
parody
massive dumps cost them the election
what is going on here what is going what
is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
dumpster
what is going on here what is going on
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive host
an executive producer of the nationally
syndicated radio
and tv program the david pacman show
and i wanted to talk to david pacman he
is a
baby david patman
he is
can you remind the audience when you
talk about
being a beta male and being an alpha
male what are we talking about here
there are males most men today yeah
they think and act like a woman they're
emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but
whoa whoa jesse well we gotta that's a
lot
that's a lot hang on agree that's raw
abortion they think and act just like a
woman
obeying a male dog but another baby
doesn't because he's a
logical thinking and they're controlled
by the darkness of david pakman
he is a beta male 1
david pacman he is a man
that made a male david pacman
he
david is he is a baby
whoa hold on a second i was enjoying
watching that and all of a sudden it
just turned off that's got to be a
complete and total accident everybody
uh no in all seriousness we've got to
get to it we are 22 minutes away from
the start of a white house press
briefing
i am expecting extremely uh perverted
and bizarre questions from peter ducey
or steve whichever one shows up today um
it will not be jen
saki it will be deputy press secretary
karine jean-pierre and if you've not
seen
karine jean-pierre do a press briefing
uh
she has a little bit of a different
approach than uh jenn saki jensaki takes
more of the
sort of like uh annoyed mom
uh approach with with the the trolling
questions
corrine jean-pierre is a little bit more
aggressive so i think it's going to be
quite a scene and we're standing by for
that and we have many many things to go
over
between now and then okay so i'm glad
that people are here for what is in all
likelihood going to be the last stream
of the calendar month known as july 2021
um what did where to even start
uh jacob asking via super chat do i
expect biden to take a hit because of
the revised mask
orders in the polling not really no not
really
um i wanna mention right now i i wanna
do this at the top of the stream
even though i'll mention it again as
more people join just because i wanna
give you guys every opportunity to
unlock a new achievement today on stream
um i have
three i teased this yesterday and now i
have them at my disposal
i have three heretofore
unseen viewer phone calls
that i think are some of the most
compelling but also
sad calls which we are going to be
releasing over the next couple of weeks
but i will preview all three for you
today if
we get to either okay a thousand
twitch subscribers which is a couple
boxes above my
head i've got boxes stacked on my head
or 100 website members and twitch subs
okay any combination a thousand twitch
or a hundred website and twitch okay
very good the three
phone calls are a 17 year old
who is desperate for me to help him get
vaccinated because his parents won't let
him
that's one call which we could look at
today
okay second call that we could look at
today
now you could wait a couple weeks and
hear these but you could also hear it
today
um a caller whose dad
anti-vac's dad died of
covid two weeks ago and his mom
will not get vaccinated okay this is
what we're up against
and then number three a caller
who is so afraid of nuclear
bombs that he won't leave his house and
i have to talk him into leaving his
house
these are sad these are sad but they are
interesting these are heretofore
unheard better said and we will
drop all three of these uh on stream
today
if we either get to a thousand
subscribers from the standpoint of
twitch it's the last stream of the month
guys
or 100 website members and twitch subs
of course the coupon code my
good until tomorrow i do want to say
thank you to dr gonzo as well as
sarah is cool for signing up via twitch
already putting us at two
now two out of a hundred that's two
divided by ten is point two 0.20
0 over 0 is 0 that's 2 percent
2 percent of the way there
couple other super chats will i ever do
a segment about the pegasus leaks
maybe bw rock what are your thoughts on
the notes released today on trump
telling doj to say the election was
illegal at the end of december yeah i
saw the new york times headline i have
not read it yet
i will study it for the monday show
and then i will have a report on that
for everybody
daniel asked david will new mask
mandates lead to more infringement on
individual rights to commerce
in the retail space um
no i don't think so
that's my hipaa guys that's my hipaa
you guys you can't even ask that that's
not even allowed you want to see
something pretty sick
um congressman paul gosar dds
by the way that's a dentist for you he
posted
a picture of himself today wearing a
for ashley wristband
now ashley babbitt was one of the
criminals who
invaded the capitol on january 6th
um paul gozar
is is yeah i don't i mean
do i even need to say anything else
i think i don't um
in terms of what's going on with the
virus usa number one
in fact i tweeted about this earlier
today
usa number one for another day in a row
92 000 new cases surpassing wednesday's
84 000.
nobody can beat us guys look at these
look at these numbers
it is just insane and we are very
quickly getting
right back into it now the good i
i will tell you the bad and the good the
good is that so far
the increase to deaths is very very low
very very low and that's partially
because of vaccination
but eventually this is going to bubble
through okay
now next week as people may know i'm
going to spain
we're hoping delta has peaked in spain
and you can see if there's a slight
decline taking place
and that's the hope and of course these
numbers reflect people infected eight
days ago
so um yeah i mean that's that's
basically it
i am going to be self schwabbing in
spain
i got a uh what was the let me see point
sky
travel covered test i ordered some tests
doctors looked at these and they said
i'm i'm likely to do really really well
with these tests
um 35 each complete
i think this is the one i got yeah i got
these tests
so basically um i bought a test and it
comes with like an
observation where somebody's gonna watch
me take the test
and then if i do well maybe i'll get
into college if i don't
i might not but that's gonna be that's
good that's what i'm doing from the
standpoint of testing
i want to say thank you to maria pete as
well as maria pete for gifting five subs
also salex dank neckbeard
joseph rader jen here
tear parker ninja 33r
oh my god okay that's eight that put oh
i'm sorry that's nine
that puts us at 11. uh also
a big thank you to daniel peterson who
just signed up on my website
joinedpakman.com that's number 12.
i have made the offer that i will
release three
really compelling phone calls on stream
if we get to either
1 000 twitch subscribers or 100 website
members uh
and twitch subscribers all right so we
we continue to stand by for karine
jean-pierre
are people asking saying something looks
a little different today yeah i shaved
yesterday
um before i never bring shaving elements
on trips
so i just did a full shave with a uh
german safety razor
really strong razor pulled out a new one
in fact i basically pull out a new razor
every other shave
is that crazy so that's why i look
different today
if people are wondering other super chat
super chats are just dumping in here
amazing stream from the standpoint of
a power fullness
sir sure david will america ever have
proportional representation
or will the republican party and
democrats rule america for the rest of
history no nobody who can say forever
who can say forever um oh
here's a chat question what uh not what
fiction am i reading right now
i'll show you right now uh
i am reading these two books
first book i'm currently reading from
the standpoint of fiction
is david foster wallace's infinite jest
very very strong book and also
reading consider i
i think it's pronounced flebus by
ian banks this is the first of the
culture series
the book's actually from 1987. i was uh
only 40 years old back in 87
and uh it's a it's very good it's sort
of like an introduction to the whole
series
from what i've been told people have
people came to me they said sir
the first one is more of like a context
for the future of that series
i'm enjoying it i'm enjoying it very
much
atheist linguist says what's sick is
that if i understand correctly we've
been reduced to literally paying people
to get vaccinated yeah
joe bi new york city's paying people 100
bucks and joe biden is encouraging
everybody
to uh pay a hundred bucks and
and i mean look at what's going on eric
topple posted this
this is louisiana it's gone vertical
look at that they've gone from about
eight cases per hundred thousand
to eighty two cases per hundred thousand
this is brutal this is absolutely insane
if this were bitcoin i'd be going crazy
i would burn the studio down
and retire if this was a chart of
bitcoin sadly it's louisiana coveted
cases
um and that's uh i mean listen we know
why we're in this
problem right and then i see the
disinfectant is there a way we can do
something like that
by injection inside or
yeah supposing we hit the body with a
tremendous
very powerful light apply light
and heat to cure supposing you brought
the light inside the body
donate plasma donate plasma today
plasma donate plasma convalesce and
donate donation
please okay so that's what's going on
um here is a newsmax guest saying
children will contract foot and mouth
disease if they wear a mask
you talk about the younger generation uh
jessie jane i think about the kids who
are headed back to the classroom in the
fall
now they're being told that you've got
to mask up uh whether or not your
teacher has or has not been vaccinated
they also have to wear a mask
how is that going to impact these kids
and their learning this year
yeah you know i'm not a child
psychologist but i'm sure that it's
detrimental to many children to have to
be on
what is your area of expertise around
with mass on
we all know by the time they come home
it's probably filthy and dirty if
anything the mask is going to give them
something else
probably hood foot and mouth disease i
mean think about that
there's no evidence of that whatsoever
has anybody in the chat heard of a
single kid getting foot and mouth
disease from a mask
over the last 18 months of the pandemic
anybody
anybody nobody has okay
i mean listen this is a retired marine
so maybe that's
is that her area of expertise they're
getting on these masks you're not
keeping them sanitary and when you've
had less than 300 children die from
kovac compared to that of the flu
rates that we've seen in previous years
uh is this really effective if the
teachers aren't comfortable put the mask
on but don't shut those schools down
there are many children
she's even talking about shutting a
school down does anybody know what she's
referring to there i don't even know
what that's about
so that's a marine uh talking about foot
and mouth disease
recordatron asked david have you managed
to get access to vaush's routers to get
the oranges
of the giga cringe scandal not yet i'm
i'm looking for the routers
i tested positive for the virus
yesterday during my routine testing
breakthrough in massachusetts very mild
symptom not sure of delta yet almost
certainly delta yeah i mean i think
we're more than 90
delta in the u.s now they need to lock
up non-vaxxers until they comply yeah
that's
that's crazy that's not going to happen
cephehide
what was the context yeah that's a
classic cephei
sefer hyde that was trump uh listing
companies that were
involved in elements of medical
spacex's autonomous spaceport drone
ships for rocket landings are named
based on the ian banks novels i did not
know that
biden bribing u.s citizens in a quid pro
quo scheme
in order to defeat kovid yeah that's the
headline we would expect to see in a lot
of places
um okay guys we have a challenge today
because it is the last
live stream of the month i have three
phone calls
one from a kid who won't leave his house
because he's scared of nuclear
uh bombing and i convince him to go for
a walk that's an interesting call
a 17 year old who's trying to get
vaccinated and his parents won't let him
and very tragically a viewer whose dad
died of kovid and his mom still won't
get vaccinated i will
play these for you today if we either
get to a thousand twitch subscribers
we're 134 away or between the website
and twitch 100 people
sign up and you can use the coupon code
myhipa that code
dies tomorrow night okay it'll be better
than trump's chances at reinstatement
tomorrow night you can sign up at
joinpakman.com with the code myhipa
these are very solid very very solid
phone calls
okay let's do a couple of unban requests
i do have my gavel here when people uh
inevitably say things on twitch and
youtube that are inappropriate
we ban them and we ban them fully and
completely
on twitch you're allowed to appeal that
ban and sometimes i will overturn
a ban if the reason for overturning is
relevant let's go oh hold on and i
forgot uh
thank you for 10 gifted subs to an
anonymous gifter
thanks to death doves sonia bratis
jen here for gifting two and then two
more
and then mog y for signing up that's 17
putting us at 29. also thanks to
dinan cleo number 30. so we are getting
there okay
user brian two blazed
showed up yesterday for the first time
subscribed i mean sorry followed on
twitch
within five seconds posted i will die
before i put a mask back on they were
banned
their unban request is what a loser of a
mod
did this i hope your whole family gets
the virus
that is a very very easy permaban
making it very very simple today for
this court to make decisions
next unbanned request is uh well that
actually moved my mic down
yeah wow look at that we got to keep
that mic up
okay uh next user is goes by the name
affinity
they showed up and they said uh hold on
a second
critiquing mrna is not anti-vaxx it's
not a vaccine it's gene therapy do you
know what mrna is do some research then
and then stfu
the goal of mrna is to alter your gmone
that's the best
they wanted to say genome and they said
instead that it alters your gmone
that's a different problem altogether um
fetal tissue also used to create
vaccines
they were then banned for endless
anti-vaxx propaganda
their unbanned request is i don't know
why i was banned please
unban unfortunately if you don't
understand why talking about mrna
altering the g-mone
is not okay you are permabanned there is
no place here for you
all right so that is uh that is today
from the standpoint of unbanned requests
that's a pretty good unban segment
actually those are interesting john if
you're watching or if you review this
later
let's clip it clip it and ship it my
friends
so two very easy perma-bans right there
i
also want to say thank you to
whoa hold on mark glander who just
signed up on my website with the coupon
code myhipa
your new member number 31 uh tiger40
as well as crowbars forever and an
anonymous gifter adding three more
subscriptions via twitch prime
putting us at 34. we have
gmon altering phone calls to play
if we do get to a hundred in the lower
bar
or a thousand up above my head
um other super chats coming
in i subscribed to your youtube
just before you started the subscriber
challenge keep up the good work
you know guys we have recently seen
a big burst of new youtube subscribers i
don't know where it's coming from but
we're up to like 7 800 a day we were
down to like 300 a day
and we're getting very very close to 1.4
million
i don't know what the explanation is
just the last week there's been a
really a pop um
and that's been a great thing highly
recommend
excuse me i should take a sip of water
highly recommend dr malka older's
sentinel cycle for your fiction reading
she's also a humanitarian worker
disaster response researcher
yeah i think she follows me on uh
twitter
infomocracy is a malka older book that i
read
very good book infomocracy
will you please look up the word
i don't know about that i don't know
what i'm looking up
pride in having a conscientiously
ignorant or close-minded way of thinking
sort of seems to overlap with
dunning-kruger maybe
sometimes you appeal bans if youtube
lets you i didn't know
no more man mask mandates vaccinated are
protected it's not quite so simple
uh we are going to remove that one i
just can't have that
uh the reality is much more complicated
than that so i'm gonna have to remove
that
i wanna say thank you to lamar moore for
signing up
at the joinpacman.com with the coupon
code myhipa you are number 35 today
also want to say thank you to miles
cornish paco taco
or paco taco however you pronounce it
for signing up via twitch prime
also thanks to death doves for
subscription number 38
and lisa is it lisa ride
lisa ridge who signed up on my website
with the coupon code myhippa
you are number 39. speaking of hipaa
here is alan dershowitz saying
on fox news that it would be perfectly
legal to mandate mask
to mandate vaccination and um
laura ingraham doesn't like it the you
know how infectious this is how many
people it kills this is not smallpox so
it's
not today literally the cdc released
something
saying that it actually the delta
variant is as contagious as smallpox so
that's interesting
it's fully approved it's not a fully
approved vaccine either
neither was the smallpox vaccine in 1905
correct
i think it is worse than smallpox in
many ways it may not kill as many people
but we don't know what the long-term
impact is
i have alan dershowitz is the voice of
reason guys
100 million people worldwide 100 million
people i have a right
oh they said chickenpox sorry guys
that's a that's a mistake i said
let me take that back the cdc
has documents that say delta's as
contagious as chickenpox i apologize for
that not smallpox
that was amazing i made a mistake oh i
have the right to get on an airplane
and know that everybody on that airplane
is vaccinated
or tested you may have the right not to
get vaccinated
but you have no right to spread the
disease to me even if you won't kill me
even if you won't have you not been
listening this is harvard law school
i can't believe you i didn't go to
harvard law school but i did hear
why does it matter whether she went to
harvard law i mean it's such a stupid
thing to say
did hear the president today talk about
how
if you're vaccinated you spread the
virus
you still can spread the virus i mean
the data out of israel the data out of
the uk
they're freaking out about this these
spread it'll be spread much less
seriously look
okay what does she keep looking at up
into the left did you see that how many
times she looked up until i
spread it'll be one two seriously three
i don't know what we don't know okay you
can deprive people of their
constitutional rights
on the basis that's still there is the
spread of emotions
institutional right to get on an
airplane and to spread
the disease to me even if it's not going
to be fatal
all right i have constitutional rights
we're up against a hard break yeah so
there there is that
um let's see here
ron desantis makes me want to move out
of florida
amit surper says david sir i've noticed
a severe downward trend in the amount of
times you're saying david sir please
resume doing it since it demonstrates
the tremendous urgency of things
well uh swami live says david sir would
you be willing to give us a video tour
of your stu
studio one day maybe i think we'd have
to get to you know some really strong
number of subscribers
but we may get there today jamie lewis
just signed up with the code myhipa
and aaron washington just signed up on
my website with the code myhipa putting
us at 41.
also want to say thank you to somnium
is dreaming for the twitch prime sub
number 42.
if you're just joining us we have three
new phone calls that will not be
released publicly
for about 10 to 14 days in total
which i will play for you today these
are wild phone calls some of the wildest
phone calls
the goal is either a thousand twitch
subscribers we're 112 away
one person could dump in 112 gifted subs
right now and we could be there
or 100 website members and new
twitch subscribers um and these i i
think people are going to want to hear
these phone calls i think these might go
terra viral
at some point speaking of voicemails
let's just listen to
a couple of voicemails david sir
do you think that trump could be
referring to the 1917 flu because you
saw the movie in 1917
which was a great movie uh maybe he uh
i think trump doesn't know what he's
talking about i think trump said it
wrong once
and then uh just keeps repeating it
that's basically it
um couple other super chats here
yeah david uh paul in pennsylvania here
hey you know none of these politicians
or uh uh you know conservative uh
media hosts uh have had a come to jesus
moment what's happening i think is
they're getting pressure
from their uh you know their uh the the
corporations and the uh mega
billionaires that
uh fund their campaigns uh because as
long as this covet hangs around
these mega billionaires and corporations
cannot
achieve 100 profitability right now the
economy you know it's kind of sputtering
along a lot of people are still out of
work and everything
so you know they're not making you know
they might be making fifty percent
uh profitability instead of one hundred
percent
and they're getting tired of it because
like i said as long as this covert hangs
around
it's cutting into their profits yeah
good it's treated
okay yeah so that's that's an
interesting perspective that's an
interesting perspective
um i want to say thanks to big shonker
as well as bleep and
seller sab for the twitch prime
subscriptions putting us at 45.
also our friend lars baron roth from the
deeper shades of house
channel gifting five subs super strong
uh there by uh lars putting us right at
50
which is uh 50 out of 100 that's roughly
half
whitney says i don't know how to find
your twitch channel
twitch.tv davidpakman or just search
davidpakman on twitch
thanks also to headless chicken for the
twitch prime subscription
couple of other things to look at here
is more video from this thing yesterday
where marjorie taylor green
matt gates louis gomer and paul gozar
tried to get into a prison where the
terrorists are incarcerated and they
weren't allowed in and it's just it's
just a [ __ ] show
just a moment ago uh they told me told
us that we were trespassing
but when i went to the detention center
in california
ice and u.s marshals is that is that
even a georgia thing reversing
reversing all of the vowels she says
when
when i went rather than when i went
wonderful they gave us a full tour
and it was it was a beautiful clean
facility and i was i thought wow america
is the most generous country in the
world
and how we treat people that have broken
laws to come in our country
normally we go somewhere that's federal
we uh show our id our congressional id
430. this is so stupid
mr gates i mean it's very unusual
for members of congress anyway it's just
like one of these people who even cares
what they say
here's another one um gomer tries to
argue he has a top secret clearance
members of congress we have oversight
over federal prisons
we've got members of judiciary here
members of oversight here
both committees that oversee facilities
like this
we absolutely are not trespassing and if
that attitude
is any indication of how they're
treating their prisoners inside i have a
great concern
well if they can consider us trespassers
that fund this facility have top secret
clearance
and i know there are some i mean that
have
what on earth is going on um
here's a little more gomer federal
facilities
were mistreating abusing
people that have been arrested on
january 6 having been
to guantanamo more than once
i know that the people there just
from what little we saw from the outside
they're being treated worse there
than the bloodthirsty terrorists at
guantanamo
man this guy is completely out of his
mind that is that is something else
um wow wow wow wow
um okay let's see what else we've got
here
i've got a couple other um
i've got super chats david sir happy
friday thank you can we get lavar burton
as a guest host of the david pakman show
while you're on vacation
i would love that sell em a get out of
ban free card
trump asked doj to declare election
results corrupt yeah we're gonna talk
about that monday
i have not yet uh reviewed all of that i
want to say thank you to bravo needs
bacon for the twitch prime sub also
thanks to cacao
juniper jeff moffett and an anonymous
gifter
putting us at 55 we may do it guys it's
actually conceivable that we do it
let's listen to a couple of other
voicemails
hi david sir i just listened to your
uh bit on how to convince
republicans to be vaccinated
this guy running the idea of
using reverse psychology is intriguing i
actually think it would work
on a lot of the republicans just despite
the
the libs and own the libs yeah i think
it's a good idea to
for the left to say hey don't tell
your republican friends where to get
vaccinated we want to keep all the
vaccines for us
don't let them get vaccinated it's like
the child it's like sandbox reverse
psychology
but i think it actually would work on
some of them um
let's listen to another voicemail
republicans
okay so the question is whether i think
that joe biden is being nicer to
republicans than he other might be
because he knows that they're going to
win in 2022
and he's gonna need them yeah i don't
know
not really i mean it's conceivable but i
have no reason to think that that's what
he's doing
um
we've got a couple of other super chats
here see what's going on
voicemail hey david you keep saying that
uh
we should make ourselves available to
no avail ourselves of the uh membership
special on august 16th
well i'm thinking shouldn't it be avail
ourselves to
the membership special no no no no
um to to eva
the phrase is to avail of and it means
to take advantage of an opportunity
avail oneself of that's the that's the
right phraseology
i i mean listen it's it i certainly
could be wrong
english is my second language but the
phrase the idiom
is to avail oneself of it just means to
take advantage of something
all right so that was proper usage i
appreciate the concern but it's
completely proper
fully proper hello good morning i'm
your east coast i think i'm west coast
oh it's afternoon
good morning afternoon and evening mr
david hey
i your your title of your uh youtube is
demented
trump speech horrified worlds carries
children well it scares adults too
i'd be one of them but i want to thank
you as fierce as you are
i know that you give your commentary
hope it seems unbiased
you just want the facts the truth but
you're funny
and you don't hardly crack the smile but
i i appreciate uh the honesty which
becomes humor
and ah i'm in my 60s and i'm just
amazed at human behavior and so if
they act like this what else do they do
in their in their
private world okay
have a good day peace congratulations
sir you just won the election
i like that caller that's a solid caller
yep
definitely like her i want to say thank
you to fabian
bork bjorklund fabian bjorklund
is new member number 56. fabian did
something borderline illegal and just
signed up on my website with the coupon
code myhipa
also want to say thank you to cosmos an
anonymous gifter
the jk trolling for the
three twitch subs putting us at 59. guys
let's do it let's get to a hundred i
have three
incredibly compelling phone calls that i
will release for you
today if we get to either a thousand
twitch subs we're only
94 away or we filled this bar to 100
with website memberships
also thanks to dranoa who just gifted a
sub that's number 60.
couple other videos for people here is
marjorie green taylor
or marjorie marjorie taylor gangrene
call her what you will
um she's mad about something nancy
pelosi did listen i don't think he
i don't think she could uh she can i
don't think she has the authority to
make cops do that i don't think cops
charity to arrest anybody uh uh no
yeah no and that's uh barry loudermilk
uh he's his district is next to miami
georgia so great colleague of mine in
georgia
that's a great video i absolutely love
it but no this is actually
abuse of the capitol police nancy pelosi
abuses the capitol police she did not
protect them uh she didn't bring the
national guard in on january 6 and
yeah that that was trump actually
marjorie
man the revisionist history is just
crazy i find her vile
vile the capitol police were left out
there
to uh to defend the capitol um and some
very violent
so she's pretending like she supports
the police but where was she when
those four officers testified on tuesday
situations
and then also here she is making the
capitol police
arrest people for not wearing a piece of
paper on their face
uh or like a jock strap or something
it's it's insane
yeah marjorie traitorous green i think
that that may be the name for her
marjorie traitorous green
um jessica cartier just wanted to chime
in
to thank you david for keeping it real
100. thank you
could you imagine if the 1-6 terrorists
were treated like gitmo detainees
transported on a stretcher waterboarding
isolation for years
let me speak to the manager of the
federal prisons yeah it was a real let
me speak to the manager moment
notice how they call them political
prisoners i did notice that yeah
the name is margarine aka i can't
believe it's not butter
trailer queen be respectful sir
margarine trailer queen
geez that's maybe a little too edgy for
me
i do want to say thank you to matt 102
102 as well as margot cabot
torah chinchilla as well numbers
61 62 and 63 today from the standpoint
of twitch
let's listen to a few more
voicemails and see what's going on
hi david my name is matthew i'm calling
from san diego
just have a couple of comments i would
like to share with you
uh hope you're not too long if you and i
were to see
an adult playing with matches
and you and i tell this adult don't play
with matches and you'll get burned
and this adult burns himself i don't
know about you
but i would have very little sense baby
scenario number two
you and i are building an adult playing
with again again
being the logical and sensitive people
you and i are
so this goes on for three minutes so i'm
bailing out very sounds like a very very
nice guy but it's just not
it's just not working it's just not
working exactly
super well okay hey pacman
yeah it's pretty obvious that you're
stealing
rm brown stick with the sound boards
i don't know what that is and now with
the visitors at the video
i mean first it's the member the
majority report set
and now rm brown is he saying
arun brown or rm brown
what is he saying is it arun like the
indian name arun brown
god i don't know what the hell this
guy's talking about
nobody knows okay that's fine
um let's see what else we've got here
okay hey buddy i've been watching for a
bit
pretty sweet from wisconsin 41 years of
age male
so i was watching your video demented
trump's speech horrifies the world
um and i was watching what you played i
didn't watch his stuff
specifically i kind of get his stuff
from you um
but i was watching about the router bit
yeah i mean i can see potentially that
there
might be a hardware issue within a
router to
intercept something and potentially
change something that is more plausible
a router could intercept something and
change something but how does that
suggest that joe biden really lost
that's the question in the fibers
you know what i mean coming from china
or changing actual
mail-in ballots that's going to be more
plausible
than intercepting mail-in ballots that
have been forged
somehow all right anyway guys none of
this stuff happened so i don't even know
i don't even know what we're talking
about really
um
okay well
let's see a couple others oh hold on
first i i have to people are just
dumping in huge memberships here and
i've gotta i've gotta make sure i thank
them they call them dumps uh
ralph bess just signed up on my website
kathleen sibley just signed up victoria
matthews is a new member
that puts us at 66 also
just dropping in yumi o'connell
is number 67 putting us at two thirds of
the way
milly girl just gifted five twitch subs
bitter britters signed up
em scruss as well as singha the great
ninja lass adam david lee
and milly girl with a personal
subscription as
one two three four five ten
eleven putting us guys we might do it
we're at 78 we might do it and it looks
like there's
four people in five people now on the
website in progress in the sign up price
oh no hold on five
six seven eight there's eight people
somewhere in the sign up process on the
website we may actually do this
it's pretty obvious you're stealing
orson welsh's wells's stick by do
schtick by doing an audio broadcast
exactly
well said denver yeah yeah no that's
exactly what i'm doing
um let's listen to
a couple
oh the eggman's doing something that i
think is in poor taste listen to this
hey dave this is phil valentine
i'm calling from the ventilator i own
you
libs nah i don't like that phil
valentine's the anti-vaxx pro-trump
right-winger
who um now is on a ventilator uh
it's it's not good it's not good and
then the egg man called back in i guess
with like a real message
hi dave dave i have massive empathy for
sick people
dying people i have empathy for stupid
ignorant people okay
but when you mix the two together with
hateful
anti-semitism and racism and extreme
partisanism is that a word that's where
i lose my empathy
okay why i don't feel bad for somebody
that's dying
because they're specifically hateful and
don't believe
something because of their reasons
against uh democrats minorities liberals
whatever it is it's their own fault now
dave i
i don't want people to die i want phil
valentine to live because he said
he's gonna preach about getting
vaccinated right but i know plenty of
people that got sick from coven
that got better and now they say you
don't have to get vaccinated because
they survived it
i don't really give a [ __ ] if about
these people i really don't care
he could live because he's going to help
other people but dave again
your empathy for horrible people makes
you and democrats and liberals weak
that's why trump is going to win
probably again people are going to win
because i feel bad for people dying of
covid
then he called back about simone biles
if simone biles was white
charlie kirk and the insane right would
not be criticizing her calling her
horrible names
for backing out because of mental health
issues and supporting her team
only because of her caller shalom shalom
wow
super aggressive and then he called back
in again he did
pastor rick weil says his church had an
explosion of coma cases
and he blames them on a vaccinated
person giving it to them
true that's absolutely not factual
donald trump's endorsed candidate in
texas
lost and then donald trump claims a
victory for endorsing the wrong person
that's absolutely also anti-factual i
want to ask you dave
with republicans literally believing
things that aren't facts they believe
the opposite of facts
do you think what you're doing or what
anyone is doing in government
is progressing society like should we
just give up
because facts don't matter so when you
state facts
it just gets people on the other side
more angry with you
should we just shut up and let them
learn from their own mistakes and just
go the direction to hold on oh man oh
both so that but that's basically just
seeding the ground to them and
i don't think i'm not ready to admit we
lost let me just put it that way i'm not
ready to admit we lost
deborah dejong says david i found an rm
brown on reddit he loves you
okay great that's fantastic
i don't i don't know much about it it's
fantastic though
manuel sanchez has just signed up at
joinedpakman.com and his new member
number 79 today guys we're getting very
close i'm getting excited
i'm getting excited small small fuzzy
moss just gifted five subs
and then fish pickles signed up which is
six that's 85.
franco the 11th just signed up and
that's number 86.
we're getting there we're getting there
we really are
a couple of other super chats
uh oh i wanted to talk about gay rights
because i like i kind of understand like
having a respect for men
you know if they want to have like man
club or whatever
and you know do private things with each
other then it's like i feel like it's
some of my business
but like when it comes to like women
like i'd
obviously rather have a man because i
think women are like worse
than men in like a male chauvinist kind
of way
where it's like i think that they're the
ones
that taught men that it's okay to treat
other women that way because that's the
way that they would act
and i'm like what what is she talking
about
i'm sorry but like woman to woman like
you're different than a man you get your
period like you get
way different emotions than men have way
different hormones and it's like
you know like i just don't
want to give rights to people because
it's like that takes away my rights
as a human being wow
i don't know what she's talking about
i think like some people hail the god of
trash
because i'm like listening to some of
these like muslim people jewish people
christian people
and i'm like if you didn't tell me who
your guard was
i would probably name him trash
wow man i don't i don't i really don't
know what she's talking about
hey pacman hey pacman
how many times you gonna talk about
someone catching clothing
oh this is uh this is troy york now
someone who mocked and denied it
and say how call colvin
tucker carlson and ben shapiro are
mocking that they're saying that
we're being forced through a medium
to hear is he eating while he calls
these stupid stories
about kova deniers getting sick and
dying
i know you say you too i think he must
be eating a bag of mangoes
i've produced programs such as this
a pacman how many people have died
through the vaccines why are you
reporting this
no no no no
no okay um hi david
love your show um have a question uh i'm
not well person in politics but uh
no question according to uh the recent
uh
books that's got got uh topics about
some
the inside of um i just can't do it i
can't do that guys it's just too
ridiculous
i want to say thank you to arith
turlitzy
for uh just signing up at
joinedpakman.com with the coupon code
myhipa
putting us at 87. i also want to say
oh no that's it we are really close to
unlocking these three
of viewer calls we are only
69 twitch subscribers away from a
thousand
or we are 13 website
members away from 100
really wild stuff um
oh people want to hear oh yeah yeah
there's a new mango track
so let me see hold on let me let me see
if i can give you the genesis of the
full mango thing
uh pac-man mango
okay so uh-oh it came from this and then
now we have a song
about it
mangoes my bag of mangoes up under trump
cost me eight dollars
i love mangoes too nine cents okay
now that we are up under our body's
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't mangoes like
three bucks each
that's it i want what eight or 11 bucks
that sounds good
then the american people belie and
highway rivalry is what you're doing
bring my mangoes back down that's right
right about that the wisconsin crowd not
identifying with the mango material
proportionally affected
don't raise the price of fruit don't you
want me to be
healthy don't you okay so then that
turned into jethro bradley
making this song for us my bag of
mangoes up under trump cost me eight
dollars i love mangoes too
nine cents okay now that we are up under
avoidance regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.99
like three bucks each
that's right
okay anyway i think you guys get the
point so that's the mango arc
so to speak um thanks to jethro bradley
we very much appreciate that that's a
really nicely nicely done song
i also want to say thank you to guitar
goddess who just
gifted 10 subs putting us at 97.
we are really close and adam matano
putting us at 98. guys number 100
gets a free item from my online store
joinpakman.com
coupon code myhipa save 70
i will send you a free item the only
places we can't ship to i think are
north korea
um some places in the middle east where
where it's just a little complicated
from the standpoint of mail
anywhere that we can ship to we will
ship to okay free item for new member
number 100 join pacman.com it's
happening right now
let's do it few other super chats rm
brown is a small youtube channel that
punches above its weight in terms of
guests contributors include slavo zizek
and blen shapiro
okay doj says trump taxes must be shared
with house committee
love it mr david sir my wife and i are
now fully vaccinated in part thanks to
you sir
also love the sound board thank you
giovanni
abe says i would love to know your
thoughts on the idea of paul ryan making
a comeback to lead a third center right
party
i see it as the only salvation for the
gop i don't think paul ryan could do it
as a third party i think the question is
can
paul ryan take the republican party back
from trump
i think that's the question david they
don't want to learn because they don't
care so why teach them what we now
is fact about coivd yes
sir realistically how close is the u.s
to losing democracy it's already sort of
not
really a democracy in the sense that not
everybody's vote counts evenly
the things rich people and corporations
want are much more likely to be made
policy
so it's already kind of not um
a democracy in that sense in that sense
um okay i want to say
thank you to zachary jenkins who just
signed up on my website and his new
member number 99
guys number 100 gets a free item or
item from the online store
this is crazy what's happening here as
we stand by for a press briefing from
karine jean-pierre who's the
deputy press secretary deputy press
secretary
who is going to be 100
who is going to be it's a crazy thing um
oh and in the meantime by the way
so what i was noticing that looking at a
map
i was looking at like all the sexism and
then the obesity levels and then
um the places where there's like more
german people and where there's more
english people
right and what i noticed was that the
places where there's like german people
it's like more diversified but it's not
like extreme sexism
and it's not extreme obesity and then in
the places where
there's more english people there's like
extreme sexism
and like the one place where there's
like absolutely no germans
is like the place where there's like
extreme obesity
but i just feel like that should count
for something because
oh it counts for something all right
health is important
and obesity kills a lot of people
i don't know guys a lot of that is not
making sense
all right new member number 100 is
brendan king
brendan king just signed up at
joinedpakman.com
and his new member number 100 we did it
folks brendan if you want a free item
from my online store
get in touch info davidpakman.com also
want to say thanks to colin morris new
member 101 and look at what is happening
on twitch
i want to say thanks to miles cornish
fractured psycho
tr napsta ms unlikely gamer
an anonymous gifter franco just gifted
five
subs richie tlv is number ten
decimator is 11. jen gifted five that's
16
an anonymous six uh seventeenth gift
nate seno signed up is 18 under the
screen gifted two that's 20.
um mary e is 21.
that is 122. this
is an explosion also thanks to michael
mata for signing up with the coupon code
myhipa number 123.
i promised it guys let's look at one of
these calls
oh and damon harvey also signing up with
the coupon code myhipa
number 124. this is a record day all
right let's look at the first one
okay this is the first caller this has
not been published yet
these are really serious phone calls
okay let's listen to the first one these
will come out over the next couple why
don't we
go next to vincent from los angeles
what's going on in la these days vincent
oh um nothing nothing much i haven't
been outside in a while
personally it's good to get some of that
vitamin d you know
yeah this gets sad i i wanted to call in
and ask
basically like i listen to your show a
lot and it's an honor to speak to you
pleasure um a lot of things
outside is really like i don't know
listening to a lot of what's going on
with
the sort of purging of the republican
party and
um gets me and you know what's going on
with climate and covid
gets me really uh nervous i was
wondering if you could
maybe talk about things that have been
going on that might give you uh
like hope as to uh you know things
getting better in the world
yeah i mean listen it's like if you what
might be useful for you and maybe others
is
sign up for a good news newsletter there
are a lot of these which just tell you
about good things that have gone on you
look at
how long are people living on average
after being diagnosed with all types of
cancer survivability has gone up you
look at you know the
you can find positive things that are
going on look at the increase the
continued increased efficiency of solar
panels for example or
look at the way in which many countries
have shifted more and more
towards alternative energy you can
definitely find that stuff but
it's also a reality that there's a lot
of really bad things going on right now
i think it's important to kind of
see both you know yeah now i'm curious
when you say
you're you're not you're not not going
out
because you're depressed about all these
things that are going on and you're just
staying home right are the two things
you mentioned they're separate issues
um to some extent to some extent oh are
you like kind of depressed and just not
leaving your house
uh just dealing with some social anxiety
i don't know like
one of the greatest things that's caused
me fear is like uh
in particular like the fear of uh
nuclear
you know weaponry around the world and
that's making you
stay home in some sense
yeah yeah i mean i don't know how much i
want to
talk about it but yeah wow i mean on a
very practical level
do you think you're safer from nuclear
fallout at home
rather than you know down the street at
a cafe because it seems either way if
there's nuclear fallout
you just might be screwed i don't know i
don't know that i would worry that much
about it in that way
that's that's a very good point i guess
i'm just thinking like if there's a if
there's a nuke that's going to be
dropped
i'd almost rather be at the basketball
court or at the pond rather than in my
house because either way it's going to
be bad and i have no control over it
that's my
thought you know yeah yeah it's
understandable
yeah try to get out there maybe take a
10-minute walk today you know
yeah you know i think i'll go ahead and
do that i like now and i'll take a look
at uh some of the
things you mentioned as to uh positive
signs let's do it james
let's do it and i want to hear from you
again okay let me know how it goes
okay thank you very much great talking
we gotta get so that's depressing get
out there
that's sad that makes me sad we really
you know
staying at home in order to avoid the
bomb i mean uh
i'd rather be having a cappuccino you
know i think that's the
that's the situation for me
um all right so there's one listen guys
you if anything when i make a promise i
deliver it okay so i've delivered one of
the three
um i do want to say thank you to aaron
breed for signing up on my website with
the code myhippa also matthew bryan
numbers 125 and 126. thanks to
crystalina for the five month resub on
twitch
the master debater just gifted two subs
as well that puts us at 129. this is a
record for
months we haven't had anything close to
this for months we're standing by for
the press briefing
you've not missed the press briefing but
we are um looking at
some other uh calls that i got
and some of these aren't great
unfortunately um
here's another one okay this is this is
this is tough stuff
we have folks not only from all over the
country
but quite frankly from all over the
world who are hoping to chat with me
today
i'm going to do my best to speak to at
least a few of them let's speak
next to gabriel from colorado gabriel
you're on the air
hi can you hear me yes i can listen to
this okay
um so this is not so much a question but
i do think it is important for people to
hear
um about a month ago uh let's say a
month and a half ago
um my father who is a
you know a very loyal fox news viewer
charleston fan um contracted paved 19
and uh 61 healthy
active it um
two weeks uh and he passed away in bed
oh my god gabriel i'm so sorry to hear
that gabriel that's absolutely
horrifying
yeah thank you um so it's been a little
rough but
i want to at least take the opportunity
to make a
a lesson out of it a story for people to
hear to understand that
it i mean it could it can hit close i
could hit anybody it's
you may think your family members may
think that they are safe
yep because somebody was safe because he
took you know supplements and he
exercised and
he uh they just took him out wow
is is has everybody else seen it as a
wake-up call if people were
unvaccinated to get vaccinated
as far as i could tell at least within
the family um
for the most part people are
understanding the severity of this
yeah my mom uh he tested positive for
antibodies that she's
uh they were separated but she's
similarly in the same sort of
effects and skeptic perspective
um so she's not getting vaccinated but
at least she has
uh antibodies from electricity so you
so your your mom is aware that your dad
died of this
and she still doesn't want to get
vaccinated
yes he actually sends me a lot of reads
like aww
sort of um
these all these are like can you imagine
this you know this health expert speaks
out i guess so whatever and what not
about how terribly dangerous
the covenants are wow wow
horrifying horrifying and then here's
the last one
here's a 17 year old wants to get
vaccinated
parents won't let him okay let's hear
from a few more people people in the
audience people like you
you can talk to me through the david
pakman show discord which you can find
at davidpakman.com
discord let's go next to adam
from philadelphia adam you're on the air
uh hey i just wanted to say thanks but
um can you hear me allowing queer though
yes i can um with uh
republican parents like mine who are
completely
against the vaccine and kovanov
and versus someone who hang on
um they are not letting me take it at
all and i'm only 17
and and my mom's reasons are not
political
i know that but my dads are they are fox
viewers every now and then
they they are complete yeah they're
complete republicans and all they don't
trust the science and all that they're
though
but what is your message
to those teenagers out there who are not
allowed to get the vaccine
so to be clear you're saying you're not
al your parents won't allow you to get
the vaccine is that right
that is correct okay the first thing is
in some states you don't need your
parents to allow you to get it when
you're 17. have you first explored what
the
the law is in your state
no i have not okay so the first thing to
know is in many states when you're 17
you can just go and get the vaccine they
don't you don't need your parents to do
anything so if you were to decide that
that's something you want to do if it's
legal
you could investigate whether that's a
possibility does that make sense
yeah okay second part is how far from
being 18 are you
six months okay five months so at the
most in five months you can get the
vaccine right i mean no matter what even
if you can't get it today because of the
the you need parental permission in five
months you can get it so what i would
say is
wear a mask and be careful until that
time
i mean you know your parents better than
i do it it sounds like it's a lost cause
trying to convince them right like
you're not gonna be able to convince
them
yeah my mom um she she's actually more
like afraid of it i should say like
i think that's what you need to like we
need to understand is like
why sometimes they're not gonna be
taking it is because of
like my mom always tells it's the it's
just the style of it
and my dad says oh but you know j j
that's that's not really what modern and
pfizers are doing at all but
my mom's always saying though but
there's all these reports about j
j coming out about you know these these
heart problems and stuff that's all they
talk about
yeah i mean you know listen again the
question is does it make sense to argue
with your parents and say the risk of
covet is much greater than the risk of
the heart thing
um but i just don't know because you
might be able to go get vaccinated now
depending on the law in your state or in
five months you can i just don't know if
it's worth fighting with them i just i
don't know
yeah i never tried doing that because
again i know what they really
do believe in this is depressing huh if
i if he just wants to get vaccinated
i would try to tell him the truth and
all they they are really
they are really third against yeah they
let me ask you this adam
is your mom less against it than your
dad
um i don't think so i think she's not
really
against i think she's again more
skeptical of it she's
a skeptic but what i'm saying is if
there was one parent who would be more
okay with you getting the vaccine would
it be your mom or your dad
probably my dad yeah okay so maybe when
your mom's not around you go to your dad
and you say dad listen
i need to be protected i need to go and
get the vaccine will you come with me so
that i can get it
and just see what he says
okay i mean i don't know and again you
might be you this might be moot because
17 year olds in your state might be able
my website with the coupon code
my hipaa and his new member number 132
people confused about what is this my
hipaa thing
uh i will show you marjorie taylor green
hipa it's just making fun of these
buffoons
um this is it hold on a second let's get
the actual video here
um where is the marjorie taylor green
video
oh no
now i'm not even able to find it
there's supposed to be so many twitter
videos of this oh i guess seth
uh myers covered it so oh that's too bad
anyway in a video she says oh wait a
second this is my own clip
hold on a second hey we've got the uh
okay hold on here we go
okay take a look two questions have you
yourself gotten vaccinated and do you
disagree with the republican whip
well your your first question is a
violation of my hipaa rights
you see with hipaa rights okay so that's
that's my hipaa
and then here's like the dallas
quarterback um i don't necessarily
uh think that's exactly important
clarence i think that's hipaa
um but i understand okay anyway none of
that relates to hipaa it's just
journalists asking people questions
but that's where we came up with the
coupon code myhipa so we'll we'll run
that until tomorrow night
all right let's get to some super chats
i've missed some and i apologize
what's with all these so-called doctors
going on youtube giving misinformation
and what shocked me the most is that
they are more popular among spanish
people
do you mean spanish or hispanic spanish
means people from the country spain
um yeah i'm not i'm not sure
any thoughts on the comment pelosi made
regarding biden having
to no authority to cancel student load
debt
a student loan debt i assume you mean i
haven't seen it i haven't seen it
my understanding is joe biden could
cancel some student loan debt because
a lot of that debt is federal and thus
joe biden could do that that's my
understanding as of right now
chad says sir data in the usda market
news service database shows the weighted
average price of mangoes
decreased from 1.73 in january of 2020
to 1.15 in july of 21. where are people
getting dollar mangoes
honestly mango let's see
trader joe's for example oh these are
mango bars
i have not seen i mean i i must just be
going to the wrong grocery store
i must be going to some kind of like
hipster big city
grocery store but i'm seeing mangoes 250
each or more
where are people getting them for a
dollar fifteen i mean you know they're
organic soy
free gluten free sugar-free other than
the natural sugar
fat-free you know it's it's it's
basically nothing it's basically air
harris teeter has five mangoes for five
dollars wow i've never i don't know what
harris teeter is i don't know if that's
your friend who's a mango farmer but
that's super interesting
man i gotta get some of those mangoes i
had no idea that they were that cheap
anywhere two for a dollar
no way you guys i know about frozen
mango okay
let's go back to a couple of voicemails
here's a really drunk caller
when you talk about freedom and again i
was saying
you know reverse psychology blah blah
blah but when you talk about freedom
i don't like to be told what to do what
about the freedom to have common sense
because i started wearing a mask on
buses and transportation
in early march of 2020 i got ridiculed i
got sculpted i mean chicago i expected
it
like oh and i was only nervous because i
thought people were gonna think that i
was sick
but i still [ __ ] did it because you
know
you know here's another thing like the
mass is supposed to stop you from
spreading you know
i saw a guy on a bus here
okay he called right back for like
18 months i've been predicting the
future
like everything that's happened like in
my mind i like
knew ever since a couple months before
the pandemic started well technically
the pandemic started in november in
china of 2019
that's why it's covered 19 right but yes
very experienced every year we're going
to be having the investments i
understand that [ __ ]
okay but the one thing is
i went to urgent care because my blood
pressure was too high for
donating plasma that's why i've been so
broke this month might they they don't
let you give players watch your blood
pressure
lessons
tomorrow i'm gonna try to get a xanax
and then
take half a bar and go get plasma
i'm gonna try to be smart about this now
but
but my point is i went to urgent care
and i asked the head nurse in charge
oh man did you get a booster shot yet
and she goes no it hasn't been
recommended
she said sir now i'm for c in the future
with this variant and other variants
before it gets crazy because once they
announce it especially in areas
i don't know what he's i know guys i
don't know what he's talking about then
he called
right back again see i must have i'm not
a psychic and i don't believe in any
kind of magical [ __ ] i don't believe in
any religion
i believe that there might be there
there is
there's still there's life in other
planets but there's definitely
in other galaxies there's probably
higher intelligent life
now if you just go through the evidence
i'd rather believe in a possibility of
higher now i'm actually interested
now i want to hear this guy's theory of
cosmology intelligent life
in other galaxies than than believe in a
god on a cloud
you know anything you know for that was
created 2 000 years ago
and then yeah the jewish religion was
created
to uh what six five six thousand years
ago
this guy i think this guy might actually
be a genius let's start getting right
yeah but there's been human
civilizations for a hundred thousand
years before that
so i mean they're both bogus but
my point is i was just talking about
booster shots so i don't believe in
myself
i don't have psychic abilities but this
guy's a brilliant brilliant
like when you when you live through
enough life
and you could kind of you take facts
and you kind of you there's patterns
there's patterns
in human behavior there's patterns in
human evolution
there's patterns in all this [ __ ] he
seems to be get there's only a few
minutes between calls but he does seem
more drunk with each call
like you do i know you do you can kind
of predict it
and intelligently predict the future and
look
i swear to god i swear to god i called
you probably two three minutes ago and i
know you know what suggest to your
audience to get a booster
and then i continue to play your stream
i'm not kidding
two minutes later biden's talking about
a booster shot
what he's gonna say but like it's common
it has to be common sense
i'm not the only one i'm a dumbass drunk
yeah i'm not the only one with common
sense
this is this is maybe the best caller
now right
maybe my common sense is a little higher
maybe i have a little more sense than
the average republican yeah or
yeah the average republican who doesn't
have money notably self-aware yeah
because there are a lot of republicans i
do think he's revealing a lot of things
that are violation of hippo
rhino and giraffe though who really only
wanted the tax breaks you know there's
all money
but there's so many of them that have no
money
and they just got conned they got
brainwashed
and they got this and that [ __ ] them
get a booster he's really putting his
mangoes out there and letting us
you know really do what we want with it
um
here's here's one from this is from the
previous day
hey between me and you mr factor thank
you
you did play a couple of messages and
i'm i'd go i'm not happy about that but
i wasn't in a blackout
oh god this is this definitely violates
hipaa
this is my hipaa oh i could i kind of
remember those ones
so thank you for at least you know
i have issues you know that and i wasn't
complete
i was probably started of course i
wouldn't call you a show unless i was
drinking
who would i love watching your show
whether i'm sober or not
people will watch sober but only call
drunk yeah
but for whatever reason i lack
self-control
and when i'm drinking and uh you know
what thank you i mean
because i'm sure there was more messages
that i left that you could have played
that were so off-base but yeah no i mean
yeah
i i you know i know i know you don't
like people calling you
i mean well i don't why do i have a
voicemail number i mean to some degree i
need people calling
think about it you're such a nice guy
and there's so many people especially
through the pandemic
that have been by themselves or with
their wives or with their girlfriends or
or
gay homosexual lovers you know sure
anybody this guy doesn't care anybody
just lovers of all kinds
and they're watching your show because
you know there's been so much
less contact with human beings so when
i'm drinking and all i watch is you
every [ __ ] day
oh boy i'm actually now i'm getting
bummed out guys
you know i'm thinking oh this guy
is my friend i gotta i gotta tell him
there's like a parasocial type thing
going on my point of view
and and maybe it'll slowly leak out
like with the whole reverse psychology
with republicans you know what i mean so
no thank you i know you could oh man i
think maybe this guy should
should guest host for me next time i'm
away
um you guys want to do one more from
this guy
or do we move on i don't know
let's just see the whole chinese thing
yeah that was funny that woman after the
chinese
okay that woman who's put who put
jesus of nazareth in the same couple
sentences as donald [ __ ] trump now
yeah i grew up
catholic and i i don't believe 90
percent of the bible
and because i've been doing my research
and and
they found the dead sea scrolls and but
the point is
is jesus of nazareth was a man of the
poor and all he was really saying is
we're all connected we are probably all
one big living organism and we don't
even realize it we're all somehow
connected
and he was just saying we're all god we
we
got we are all the chosen people but i
mean that's really all he's saying
but he was a man of the poor it wasn't
until the roman catholic church accepted
what he did and made it into a rich
person thing
but but jesus all right anyway now it's
going completely off the rails i don't
know what anything is
that's about so that's it that's our new
caller uh
i don't know what his nickname would be
a little bit of a bummer
um from chicago definitely
you know seems to have an issue with uh
drinking i think it's fair to say
few super chats coming in bash brannigan
says why have no reporters challenged
marjorie taylor green that hipaa isn't a
valid excuse i don't know
sir stop and shop is selling mangoes ten
for ten dollars
i'll take a hundred wait ten for ten
dollars how much is that if you just buy
two hold on
ten divided by ten is one times
two that's three bucks right for two of
them
math is tough math is really really
tough
uh okay has the press briefing been
cancelled
that i don't know it's certainly
plausible
um it's certainly plausible yeah
hey dog b-dog here big fan of you david
pack dog uh
i just wanted to ask you about um nancy
pelosi called
uh minority leader mccarthy a [ __ ]
recently dog in regards to uh
masking in the house um is that beneath
nancy pelosi dog or do dogs like
mccarthy
uh deserve to be called what they are
dog i'll take my uh questions off the
air though
i'm in my answers dog you know what i
mean i i don't
yeah uh i don't know anything about it
i'm sorry i'm unable to say for sure
because i just don't know
a damn thing about it uh hello david
i just got finished watching uh joe
biden's most recent address to the
nation
i guess you would call it and i just
wonder why it is that we as a nation
keep uh
keep catering to people that are holding
the country back
why do we never seem to reward the
people who
make the sacrifices to keep this country
going
i don't know maybe you don't see it that
way would love to hear your thoughts on
it
well i've addressed this before which is
it's not
necessarily about catering
but if you just ignore them and let them
run rampant
then they do sort of like start to win
with their
insanity so it's kind of a complex it's
i think it's much more complicated than
that and i've addressed it before
um i think it is definitely something um
it's more nuanced than that i guess is
what i would say
hi david i'm calling from grand junction
colorado
and i just noticed that in media
coverage of
vaccine hesitancy that not enough
attention is given
to why a lot of black people are not
getting vaccinated
i think there is attention um you know
as a basis
they're the mistrust social norms
um so there's a doctor embedded out of
duke university that talks about a lot
of this and yeah
it's an issue we've talked about it's an
issue we've talked about
i thought something really interesting
to point out was that
throughout like british history there's
always like conflict
in between like british and
i don't know the families or feuds like
there's tons of
literature and glorification of like
female buying
stuff and it's just like the holocaust
like i mean it's basically
like it just seems like a parody of like
richard iii
no the holocaust wasn't a parody and it
wasn't satire no
no no no so i saw that like german
is a little bit more closely related
than
uh french to russia
um but also germans related to
the language called africans
yeah all right
hi um so i going off of what i was
talking about yesterday about
the european the audio is particularly
bad in this
call um i just had like kind of some
worries about excuse me um about what's
going on
in um iran so i noticed that there's
like
a lot of like muslims like man these are
these are really not good
exactly you're you're a hypocrite
the luck has been trying to cancel
cover crossing forever what and as
anthony blind logan and the hodge twins
point out
who who is that anthony brian logan and
the hotch twins
he watches the most obscure stuff you
know
do you ever watch other programs or you
just only
watch your own and i only watch my own
program
exactly but they point out that this dan
bailey is a federal
agent he's a globalist he's part of some
environment
is he is he saying that the guy who
confronted tucker carlson is actually
an intelligence officer is that what
he's saying the guy in montana who ran
into tucker that was a planted
intelligence officer
that's so wild i almost love it
that's amazing he had a political agenda
this was planned out this was it was an
op
man is a cia agent yeah
how stupid would it would it be like you
know we
we can we can disagree about the role of
the cia
in latin america you know we get we can
criticize
like how stupid would the cia to be like
hey here's what we're going to do
we're going to send a guy dressed like a
fisherman to uh montana
and we're just going to have him
confront tucker and tell talker he's a
bad person
like what kind of an operation would
that be
real waste of time uh
they'd let the political liberal left
the progressive fascists have been
attempting to
censor and cancel tucker carlson and
they have failed and now they're
upping a notch and going full harassment
and you're a hypocrite you're you're a
liar
this dan bailey wants to harass tucker
carlson because he has a different
opinion
uh that tucker has a different opinion
than people like you like you
psychopaths on the
on the political left and i think you're
i see in the transcript which can barely
make heads or tails out of uh troy's
mumbling that the word argentina is
there so i'm interested when he mentions
argentina
and when you have it on the shoe on
people are confronting you
you're not too happy about it and i hope
more people confront you mr penton i
wish that one guy at the restaurant had
uh
put it online he was actually a woman
run away like the scary little [ __ ]
that you are
a packaging why are you always harassing
proper girlfriend
because he has a different political
opinion
and you only want people like yourself
and shane greenberg
could he say jake quiver what is what
was that name he said
oh jenk yuger uger oh my god
what an abortive attempt there i'm
heartening
to have air time and express themselves
a pacman
are all rgt people like you fascists and
believe in
and you are are you such a hack for are
you on the payroll of venezuela
no i'm against the venezuelan regime the
left actually some people in the
revolutionary left don't like me
because i am not a fan of any
authoritarian regime like the one in
venezuela hey
uh pacman uh
what's your deal with dr carlson are you
jealous all right we're now go
just going in circles then this may have
been him again i don't know
and gretchen whitmore michigan
to repress the individual rights and
freedoms of the people of michigan
or how about pennsylvania scumbag and
ugly all right
i gotta dump it big massive dumps we got
to get out
yep they call them dumps that's what we
we we've got to dump the calls uh okay i
am being notified that the press
briefing actually may have been
cancelled that there's some issue with
the biden schedule and everything that
it appears that it may not be happening
they are now more than a full hour late
so um let's let's end the stream here
and i will monitor and come back if
indeed it seems as though
this press briefing is uh going to
happen oh wait oh it's happening hold on
wait
oh here we go oh it is happening
beautiful
perfect all right so let's keep it going
um they're controlled by the darkness of
david patman
yes exactly
uh okay good so we're actually gonna get
a press briefing it's unbelievable i'm
shocked that it's actually happening
i wanna say thank you to charles kirkman
for signing up on my website with the
coupon code myhipa
new member number 133 today also thanks
to becca rizzo
and manuel ayes for the twitch prime
subs number
134 and 135
this is a record stream from the
standpoint of
numbers super super strong
if you're just joining us we're
anticipating peter ducey to ask
completely unhinged and corrosive
questions this is peter ducey right here
so he is in the room today's press
briefing is going to be handled by the
deputy press secretary karine
jean-pierre
they were waiting for you to threaten to
shut down the stream exactly
that's why they did it now that's why
they signed up
will i do anything special if we do get
to a thousand twitch subs
uh yeah i mean i'll cheer it it would be
pretty interesting
who are the top gifters right now top
gifters of all time i'm inconsolable has
gifted 550 subs on twitch
david chadman is in second place with
363.
and spudnik is in third place with 258
then there's a whole bunch of other
people
odw astrolycos ky dizzle
etc etc rjc at one point was in the top
three with 70 but now has been relegated
to 10th
which is that's pretty far down that's
pretty far down i have to tell you
i would tune in every day if you did
live events daily there really aren't
things every day like sometimes i'd
really be reaching it wouldn't it would
be like you know
uh nancy pelosi answers three questions
like i don't know that that's worthy of
a stream necessarily
all right here we go oh hold on let's go
over here i think this stream might be
stronger
mission preparedness and response
activities
this was a follow-up to the meeting the
president convened
last month with cabinet officials
governors from western states
and private sector partners during
today's event the president highlighted
the heroism of our firefighters
who undertake dangerous work to keep
americans safe
and he discussed the actions his
administration is taking
to improve emergency preparedness and
keep americans
safe the president and the vice
president then received an update from
the governors about the situation on the
ground
they discuss what their administration
can do to support
state and local response efforts and
ensure
the federal government's response is a
quick and effective
as possible driven by extreme heat
prolonged drought and the change in
climate
i've got a delivery guys i'll be right
back forest management decisions
the 2021 wildfire season continues to
outpace the devastating 2021 season in
terms of large fires to date
already this year fema has approved 20
fire management assistant grants to help
states pay
for the cost of fighting these fires the
president has been receiving regular
reports
on how wildfires are impacting
communities across
the country and he will continue to
close
to closely monitor the severity of this
situation cuba
on cuba meeting today that the
president's having since the historic
protest
we witnessed in cuba on july 11 the
president has been watching the events
closely
as we have stated before he's made clear
that cuba is led by a failed
and repressive regime and that communism
is
is a universally failed ideology that's
why from the start the president has
said that addressing
this moment was a priority for the
administration
we have said many times that cuban
americans are the best ambassadors for
freedom and prosperity in cuba
as part of that today the president will
host
cuban american leaders at the white
house to discuss the demonstrations
and the administration's response in
addition we'll we will we
also announced yesterday that the
president is nominating
cuban-american frank mora to be the next
u.s ambassador
to the organization of american states a
vital
forum where we have and will continue to
regularly urge
the countries of the hemisphere to
support a fundamental freedom
the fundamental freedoms of the cuban
and i know you love these this is of our
vaccination update they're so great
we are always happy to share them with
you so today we recorded over
half a million new shots in arms the
highest number since
first of july and the average number of
people
getting their first shots each day is up
30 percent
over the past week alone and this is the
third week that states with the highest
cases have the highest vaccination rates
every day americans are making the
choice to get vaccinated
this is an encouraging sign but we need
everyone across
the country to have the conversation
with someone they know who is
unvaccinated about getting the shot
this is how we will stop the spread of
the delta variant
and as we all know save lives
finally i have a quick preview of the
week ahead for all of you the next week
this next coming week the president will
continue engaging
with members of congress to pass the
bipartisan infrastructure deal
which will deliver historic
infrastructure investments
that will drive economic growth and
create
good paying middle class jobs also next
week the president will meet with dr
eric lander
his science advisor and director of the
office of science and technology policy
about
his plan for preparing for future
pandemics
on tuesday the president will deliver
remarks on the administration's progress
delivering vaccines
to the world to fight this pandemic
globally
on friday we will deliver remarks on the
jobs report
as you all know the first friday of the
month and
um lastly president biden will then
travel to rehoboth
beach delaware will he remain over
the weekend alex please take it away
sure
um so i know we haven't heard about it
three times so
i have a couple quick questions um
first the eviction moratorium um
lawmakers are scrambling to find a
legislative solution that speaker loki
said today
that you'd like to see the cdc extended
i know you all have cited the supreme
court decision it's the reason progress
needs to
deal with it but why not just extend it
have that legal fight
and give congress a little bit more room
to work so as as we've stated
alex um and to your point about pelosi
you know this as
the supreme court said it could only be
extended with congressional
authorization
that was their decision that's how they
were able to strike it down
and that's what they said needed to
happen and so did we try the other
stream
deal with it but why not just extend it
have that legal fight and give congress
bit
so as as we've stated alex um and to
your point about pelosi you know this
the supreme court said it could only be
extended with congressional
authorization
that was their decision that's how they
were able to strike it down
and that's what they said needed to
happen and so this this bill
that pelosi's is asking for uh
this would meet that requirement if
successful so this is important
important it's incredibly important to
to move forward
and so the administration is working is
going to work together with leaders in
congress
on potential avenues to extend the
eviction moratorium to protect these
vulnerable renters
and their families we understand how
critical that is how important that is
it has been a lifeline to so many so
many
americans here so this is a public
health concern as you can imagine
that we think should be supported by
both republicans
and democrats so we support the
speaker's effort and we will do
everything
that we can to move this forward on
voting rights can you tell us any more
information about how the program is
meeting with schumer and pelosi on
the sort of efforts around the world
absolutely
oh go ahead i'm so sorry
so as you stated the president and the
vice president are hosting
speaker pelosi and leader schumer at the
white house today later this afternoon
and this is they're doing this because
they want to make sure that they
continue having
the conversation on protecting the
sacred right to vote
because it's such incredibly uh it's an
incredible priority
uh for them uh the the president and the
speaker the
leader schumer are regularly in touch
about this but they wanted to have this
meeting in person to talk about the next
step this is
both personal to the president as we've
talked about many times
having fought for voting rights his
entire life he spoke about it in
pennsylvania
not too long ago just a couple weeks ago
and he's going to just continue having
those conversations
and one more on the cdc document that
was just linked
the washington post obtained a cdp
powerpoint that suggests that the
situation surrounding the delta variant
is more dire than you know the
administration has characterized it
i wanted to read a few quotes from it it
said
given higher transability and current
vaccine coverage
universal masking is essential to reduce
transmission of the delta variant
delta variant breakthrough infections
may be as transmissible as
unvaccinated cases and quote risk of
infection is reduced
threefold in the vaccinated population
and so president biden has repeated over
and over
that this is a pandemic of the
unvaccinated but this uh
california seems to raise questions
about that
um he's also promised to level up with
the american people so his comments
yesterday
was he being completely upfront about
the challenge for the delta variant
this powerpoint would suggest it's a
little bit more dire than
he laid it out to be and why wasn't that
powerpoint made public why did it have
to be
to the public and then lastly more
questions
i mean it is a little crazy this is like
the one person at the dinner party who
speaks 95 percent of the time even
though they're one of 12 people
areas of high transmission when the cdc
seems to be suggesting
universal mapping okay alex that was a
lot
no i appreciate the question it's
actually a very important question and
we need to
and i'm happy to to address all of them
so since may just wanted to step back a
little bit since may
the cdc and the administration have been
crystal clear about the increased risk
of the delta variant in our pandemic
response and so everybody's so
confused examples because this is such
an important moment that we're in in
fighting this pandemic so in may out of
the concern
of the spread of delta we restricted
travel to india where it was growing
that is something that we did in may and
so that as you know that was many months
ago at this point a couple months ago at
this point
in the month of june doctors from the an
admin blitzed local constituency
and national media with over 400 media
interviews with a clear message
delta is a serious threat and getting
vaccinated
is the clear solution so that was in the
month of june for the month of june
throughout june
the president jeff science and our
medical experts spoke
dozens of times to the threat of delta
po the threat that delta post it's a
little funny how only a thousand people
are watching the actual white house feed
of this
but like 4 500 are watching it on my
platforms it's it's like none of the
numbers are big but
the white house channels get very little
interest of recent reporting
it is worth noting that dr wilinsky said
eight
days ago that the delta variant is the
most infectious respiratory disease
she's been she has seen in the last 20
years her 20 years of her career
our message has always been clear
throughout
we need to get vaccinated to stop the
spread
of this variant and so we have to
continue to make that
effort vaccinated and unvaccinated
people infected with delta
have higher viral loads meaning
more virus in their body than with
previous variants
the last two did not have that and so
this is what we're seeing in the delta
high viral loads mean you are more
likely to spread it
so in the rare occasions that we're
almost through the first question
in a breakthrough infection they may be
contagious and this is what we heard
from cdc this week and so the most
important takeaway and i want to be
really clear about this because this is
critical
for for all of you who report about this
and for those who are watching
we should have to take aways we should
have from this guidance
and any follow-up reporting is actually
pretty simple
we need more people to get vaccinated
that's the answer we need
more people to get vaccinated that's if
we want to stop the spread of this
variant
and avoid mutations we can so we just
need to get more people vaccinated
and the good news is that the vaccine
the vaccinations the vaccines work so we
got to get out there and make sure
people get better convalescent plasma
the president said for the early months
of this administration that those who
were vaccinated
and wearing masks and doing all those
steps could look toward the 4th of july
as that independence opportunity
we now know the cdc is basing some of
this new science
on a fourth of july party that happened
in massachusetts
where the delta variant uh was
predominant
we saw that vaccinated people were
passing it and so forth
does this give the president pause about
making recommendations about what the
public can do
because he encouraged people who were
vaccinated to gather on the 4th of july
a group that did so is now sort of a
poster example
for the cdc of what can happen with this
period i mean you know kelly oh
his the president has always said he's
going to follow the science
and he's going to listen to public
health experts that's what we do
right that's why we're we we are all
following the cdc guidance
on masking and so that's that's our
north star
as we as jen has said uh earlier this
week look
the job of all of us in this room is to
communicate the truth about where we are
in the pandemic and this is the
something the president has said
from the from day one and also highlight
how we can get out of this pandemic
so the vaccines work that's the truth we
know masks work
that's the truth they save lives and
prevent spread of this
dangerous delta variant so we need to
help in communicating the actions we are
telling
the american people to take and getting
vaccinated and wearing a mask
if you're in an area where there's lots
of virus circulating it's more
contagious
you have to wear a mask i know i have
one more question that i actually didn't
get to find i hope she answers what's
going to happen with mangoes up under
biden
more data publicly or this data
so just wanted to say that um the cdc's
first and foremost priority
is getting the american people
information as quickly as possible
and so that's what they did on tuesday
they got it as quickly as they can
they're going to be releasing this data
today as you know and it was clear that
the fact
it was clear that vaccinated people had
the ability to transmit
and and action needed to be taken
quickly and that's why they did it
they did it ahead of releasing the data
and they're going to do that today as i
just mentioned
this is also in terms of getting
information out like why are the doctors
not here in the briefing room to take
our questions
why have we not had a covered briefing
when we got some update from
dr wolinski that was a phone briefing
provides information but the public is
eager to know more
about what the delta variants can do you
know what kelio i would
i would um argue that we had the
president of the united states
speak to this yesterday he gave a more
than 30-minute speech
about where we are as a country i mean
he is
a trusted voice he's the leader of our
country
no but we heard from him right we heard
from the president yesterday we heard
from the president
about the delta variant and vaccinations
in general
the day before yesterday when he was in
pennsylvania when he was supposed to
talk about
buy american which he did but he let off
why haven't
you brought in the doctors that my
right-wing colleagues in this room will
assail the character of
mercilessly talking probably all of them
talking about
the delta variant all throughout these
last couple of days
so they have been out there they have
been talking about it and yeah we heard
from directly from dr lewinsky herself
you know so lewinsky oh boy continue to
do we're going to continue
to make sure that we come lewinsky is
that's that's a bit of a people and also
hand
work hand in hand with local governments
and state governments as well
that's good thank you just to follow up
on all of that um
you mentioned the cdc's data that was
released on tuesday
i think the question is why doesn't that
guidance
match the internal memos guidance
because
on tuesday they updated the masked items
to say
you only have to wear it in places that
have high or moderate transmissibility
the internal memo that was leaked says
given higher transmissibility and
current coverage
vaccine coverage universal masking is
essential
to reduce transmission so one why don't
the
recommendations match and two should
the american public anticipate updated
guidance that includes
universal masking and also new guidance
about large gatherings
and how many people should gather given
what we are seeing from provincetown
well
as you know weeja we do not make those
types of
you know decisions from here when it
comes to the science when it comes to
guidance that that comes from cdc so the
questions that you just asked me
i refer you to cdc about the slides and
the
what you saw in the slides specifically
that comes from them
and they will have that uh specific um
you know kind of uh information for you
that you're you're trying to get here
i will say though i think the most
important thing and i don't want to get
away from this
because this is what's the most critical
thing here is that people need to get
vaccinated
that's the answer if we want to make
sure that we curb
uh this pandemic that we curb this the
cove in 19 that we fight that we win
this fight that we're in
yeah the answer to all of these things
is sort of like hey you know what
we're trying to keep up with a changing
situation
masking and gatherings are going to be
off and on up and down
until enough people get vaccinated
that's the top line and everything else
is just going to be us reacting to
what's going on as not enough people are
vaccinated
right we're talking about older people
in our lives that we want to make sure
are taken care of and so that is if
anything that is
should be one of the main reasons people
get vaccinated to make sure they take
care of their families and their
community
has the white house reviewed the cdc's
internal medals
i i don't have anything to to say about
that
i could look into that the analogies are
helpful to understand like
you know they're that the delta variant
is as
contagious as chickenpox or more
contagious than the common cold or ebola
are these things that
they're going to present to the public
to help ebola is not that contagious
right because it's only spread through
fluids i don't know why even she's
mentioning ebola right
so it'll be it'll be available it's
being released today
yeah and one more just follow up on
kelly of all the weeks
not to have a copic briefing why this
week
yeah ebola is only a 1.5 to 2.5 r
the doctors have been on national
television
all week speaking to this answering the
questions
uh on your neck on your networks so oh
an article mentioned it okay
hiding they're actually having the
conversations
with anchors and hosts and answering the
hard questions about the delta variant
about the cdc masking
and so they've been out there they're
not hiding they're actually speaking to
this
almost every day so you know and
and we heard from the president of the
united states yesterday for more than
30-minute
speech that many of you were in so thank
you
thank you all right building off of your
here we go
then why is the president asking
vaccinated
people to mask up if there have been
just 0.0035
of the 161 million fully vaccinated
americans
who've had a breakthrough case whoa
we'll give you the facts about the delta
variant
and maybe this this will help peter it
spreads more than twice as easily from
one person
to another and it's spreading rapidly it
is really just across the country
and that is just the fact two months ago
only one percent of covet in the u.s
were
delta now more than 80 percent
are delta and so this is where we
we are today with this vaccine and so it
is we are listening to
the experts the cdc guidance and this is
what they are telling us if you live in
an area
that has that is highly contagious um
and that has high levels
you have to they are saying they are you
know giving the guidance
i love how everybody has to respond as
if the reporter
really wants to get a substantive answer
rather than just confront
preliminary stuff we've seen from the
cdc says this new guidance for
vaccinated people to mask up is based on
data from people who got sick
partying in providence town
massachusetts has the white house seen
any proof
that covet is spreading vaccinated
people are spreading
kobit uh who are not going to big
parties
here's what we we know and i'm just
going to repeat again we need to get
people vaccinated that
that is really the answer here that is
what we're seeing from
that's what we're hearing from cdc
that's what we're even seeing from these
slides is that people need to get
vaccinated
that is how we fight the delta the delta
variant that is how we fight covet and
then last one
the president said yesterday it is still
a question whether the federal
government can mandate the whole country
to get vaccinated he said i don't know
that yet
does that mean he has asked the justice
department to see
if it's legal to make everybody get it
so uh what when he said that across
about the mandate across the country
um you know i would encourage you to to
read his statement
uh and make sure you read the contents
of his remarks
so a national vaccine requirement is not
under consideration
at this time that's where we at this
time
he asked the judgment
i don't have any more to add to that
okay okay
that will be the subject of a few uh fox
news stories later today
100 cases 74 of people there fully
vaccinated
so doesn't that at least suggest that
maybe breakthrough cases
aren't rare but that's not what the
that's not what the data shows us that's
not what we've gotten from cdc
we've been we we know that it is the
breakthroughs that
do happen with vaccinated people are are
rare
and so right now what the cdc has told
us is because they do
know that there are some breakthrough
cases we have to we have to make sure
we're masked
and so again we just have to continue to
make sure people get vaccinated
that is the answer that's how we got to
move forward and that's what we're
focused
on here at the white house so we're
supposed to see that as more of a
one-off
event no that's why well i'm what i'm
saying
is that what we're focused on our
message is very very
clear is that we want to make sure that
people get vaccinated
that is yes that is one event but what
the cdc
uh that what the cdc guidance tells us
is that the breakthroughs have been
where this is what the public health
officials have said
like yes there are breakthroughs but
they have been rare but the problem is
that they are it is now contagious right
and so
that's why they're asking us to wear a
mask where before with the last two
variants that we've seen
we weren't seeing that we weren't seeing
vaccinated people
pass that along and so now that has
changed with the delta variant that is
how serious
this variant is that's why our message
continues to be
please get vaccinated on the eviction
moratorium speaker close the
understatement said that only 3 billion
out of an allocated 46.5 billion has
actually gone out the door
so what is the administration doing to
help get more money out the door faster
yeah so um that's a good question
because that shouldn't be
happening right we we we are aware that
the monies are taking some time to get
to the
some time from it's already out in the
states sometimes
getting to where the folks really need
it the rental the
renters and lawmakers so what we have
done these past couple of days is we
made an announcement last week that 1.5
billion
dollars of that era went out
in the month of june and that was the
most that we saw in
the last five months and so we continue
to
continue to work uh to make sure that
people are
being made aware that this is this is an
existence look this this shouldn't be
happening
states should be making sure that these
monies are getting out as quickly
as possible and so we and just yes just
just this week we had a day of action to
promote the availability of the rental
assistance
which reached tens of millions of
americans last week the
treasury released new data which i just
mentioned with the 1.5 billion
and then so what we know is that these
funds can continue to be dispersed
to renters and landlords until until
2025
and so these emergency rental assistance
are so critical they're so important
and so we're making sure that we
continue to work with uh local
local governments to get that out yes i
think people are applying
we've heard tens of thousands of people
have a pie they're just
waiting for the funds to be first yeah i
hear you and that's why we're
encouraging the states to get that out
as soon as possible they have it they
need to get that out
yeah uh corey given the seriousness of
the delta variant
are there conversations in the white
house or between the white house and
scientific advisors about more lockdowns
partial lockdowns or anything along
those lines
so that is something that you know i i
know this was asked to me yesterday
uh the way we see this is that we have
the tools in our tool belt
to fight this this this variant to fight
this vaccine
and we we are not we are not going to
head towards a lockdown we want to make
sure
that we're doing everything that we can
because
after passing the historic rescue plan
we have the resources
to make sure that doesn't happen so our
role again is to make sure
that we get that we get people
vaccinated as quickly as possible look
this vaccine these vaccines are free
they're easy
to get they've never been easier to get
vaccinated so that is the number one
thing that we're trying to do is making
that happen we have the resources to do
that
that's what we've been able to do this
past six months we've been able to get
more than 160
million people fully vaccinated eighty
percent of that
or are uh are in
our people who are over the age of 65
and so that's what we're going to
continue to do and so
our goal is to make sure that we are not
headed towards that
that is not going to be the the the
direction that we take
because we have the tools to prevent
that yeah that wasn't so good federal
new
requirements for federal workers could
be a example for other employers
can you just explain will federal
employees data be collected
when they submit their vaccination
status and
will the federal government be paying
for the tests that they take
if they do not attest to being
vaccinated so the agencies will pay for
the cost of regular federal employee
screening tests so that's how that's
going to to move forward and they're
going to implement
the agencies are going to be
implementing this program themselves
uh so they'll be in charge of of that
how that moves forward
and and so that's kind of how how that's
going to be dispersed we're banning a
lot of people it's crazy
lastly the new york times reporting and
others says president trump
pressed the justice department last year
to declare falsely
that the election was corrupt uh do you
have a reaction to that
and with you know your justice
department the bible justice department
do anything about that so president
biden has been clear that he believes it
is absolutely vital to have a department
of justice that is free
from undue political influence and these
revelations
underscore why that's important
follow up on mary alice's question her
number at least percentage-wise was
right from the cbc
study it says about 74 of 346 cases
have been fully vaccinated in that
cluster so just to clarify
it's still the belief of the
administration and the public health
officials that break through cases
are rare on that so what we've been what
have you been told by cdc and what we
know from our public health house
expert is that they are rare but here's
i mean but here's the thing and this is
what we keep trying to say
is that we got to get people vaccinated
that is
that is what we have to focus on that is
why we're seeing the delta variant
and and so that is what we're working on
as as an administration
that's what the president talked about
he talked about incentives he talked
about ways
uh to do this in a more robust way
and this is the way we're gonna be
focused on is making sure people get
vaccinated so that actually
that was my follow-up which is you know
it's very clear
that those who are vaccinated see your
symptoms hospitalizations
that there's no question about it when
you look at the data how concerned are
you guys that people see
a headline like that about breakthrough
cases or a headline from the slides
about transmissibility and it undercuts
it's funny the people writing the
headlines that undercut the vaccination
effort are asking how they see those
headlines
did you guys see what just happened
numbers and people getting vaccinated
and so if anything we're seeing people
are
out there who are unvaccinated clearly
getting vaccinated and so that's that's
critical that's important the numbers
and the data shows that
uh and so that's what can we do about
some of the headlines that are making
people
less uh interested in getting vaccinated
like the ones my media outlet publishes
for example every single day at a
certain point we were not being tested
i'm curious what the current status of
staff white house staff testing is
and whether giving the students about
transmission their plan to ramp up that
so we're going to continue to follow uh
the guidance that's been let out that's
been that's been handed
and so all of that is going to be
determined our testing is going to be
determined by the white house medical
unit
we continue to get tested here the staff
does uh so does the president
um and so that's what we're gonna that's
what that's that's how we're gonna
continue to move forward when you say
guidance is that uh
i think the current guidance is only if
there are symptoms if you're vaccinated
is that the current state yeah
we've also we've also have stated in the
past like when we when you're around
when a staffer's around the president
they get tested and because of we're
around the president of the united
states we get tested pretty regularly
that's something that we have shared
in the past there's nothing new there
and we're gonna continue to
to follow what the white house medical
unit uh
entails for us to do as staff and for
the president
um on the eviction moratorium why did
the white house wait until yesterday
to publicly inform congress that it was
then we needed to extend it
legislatively
so let me just first say um about the
eviction moratorium because this is i
think really important we know that this
has a disproportionate effect on those
americans both most likely to face
evictions and lacking vaccinations and
president
biden would have strongly supported a
decision by the cdc to further extend
this eviction moratorium
to protect renters at this at this
moment of heightened vulnerability
but like we've all said today
unfortunately the supreme court has made
clear
that this option is no longer available
so
the supreme court's ruling stated that
clear and specific congressional
authorization
would be necessary for the cdc to extend
the moratorium
through july so one of the things that i
do want to say that we have been doing
we have had this whole of government
effect to get the word out about the
availability of the rental assistant
and to support uh grantees to ramping up
their efforts
and so that is our focus because we know
that getting that funding to renters
and landlords is incredibly key and
important so we've been doing that since
day one and now what we're saying right
now what we have been saying is that
we're going to work
with congress to make sure that we're
able to extend it we support
speaker pelosi and her in her efforts
and what she is trying to do
actually speaks to what the supreme
court laid out in making sure that
there is a continuation of the eviction
moratorium right but the supreme court
ruling was more than a month ago and you
waited until this week to tell congress
that they needed to do and you
effectively jammed them
too nasty we've been having
conversations with congress
for some time about this uh this is
something that we
have been working with them uh on some
with some time about
how we move forward and so this is so
this is we're gonna continue to do that
and we appreciate speaker pelosi's
efforts and we're gonna work closely
with her on getting that done and
again from day one this administration
has been working
to make sure that we we really take care
of the most vulnerable
in this country who's been affected by
cobalt 19.
there was some confusion over military
service members
being mandated to get the vaccine um
the president said yesterday with all
that timing
um and recommended the dod study it the
dod later put your own statement up
but what do you mean it's all about
timing when he also said that
the numbers are going to get worse
before it gets better so uh i'll say it
is the president
is asking the department of defense to
look into how
and when uh and when they will add covet
to the list of mandatory vaccinations
uh for for there for our armed forces
anything else i refer you to the dod for
both civilian and military
services i just know it's the department
of defense that's who
that's who he's been talking to about
getting that done
um okay just on a separate note um it
was reported this morning that
uh senator cinema a key down swing vote
said she will be not putting off august
vacation plans to vote on your
3.5 trillion reconciliation bill
what's your reaction to that uh look i
know that this has come up and i just
want to be
uh really clear about this and what she
actually
what cinema actually said and so um
you know i'm not going to clearly
negotiate or anything like that at the
podium but it's important to be clear
about
what the senator said she is going to
vote to proceed with the debate
on the budget resolution she expressed
reservations
about the top line which she's been
clearly clear about
and other senators have said the same
but she's standing she's not standing in
the way of moving this
this process forward thanks
you've been clear that the position of
the administration is around the
importance of getting vaccinated but i
had a follow-up to alex's question
earlier because a lot of americans
do not know if they are in an area with
substantial or high levels
of training just google it while you are
trying to get vaccination rates
of is it the position of the
administration that local officials
in those affected areas should bring
back mass mandates
well local officials are going to look
at the
vaccination rate in their area and they
have the flexibility to put that into
place to put mandates into place as
we've seen across the country
that is not our role here as as a
federal government we are not mandating
uh mask wearing we're following again
cdc
guidance and we encourage we encourage
local governments and states
uh to to adhere or to to take a look at
the guidance
and make sure that they keep people safe
right they keep their communities safe
and they keep people in their state safe
so that is what we encourage
and at the same time i'm going to be a
broken record on this because
this is true this is the case we have to
make sure we continue
to get people vaccinated and a question
with respect to cuba and the ongoing
policy review i know there's a meeting
today but has there been any movement on
actionable steps
specifically does the president plan to
lift travel restrictions between the us
and cuba and make it easier for cuban
americans to send money
uh to their relatives on the island both
of which are which are issues he
campaigned on yeah
and uh both important issues that we
understand to the cuban people
so we're not going to preview any
specific actions here
um that is not something that i'm going
to do from the podium
i will say that on the remittances
this is a complex issue that requires
coordination with experts that will help
to inform the administration's policies
so at the president's direction the
department of treasury
and state will form a remittance working
group to review events that sounds like
it's going to take a long time
follow up please right right back here
and follow up on cuba please
thank you so much uh you may have
noticed those protests last week
across the street from the white house i
don't know if you or anybody from the
white house happened
to speak to those protesters but i did
and
it's anecdotal of course but they say
they see no difference between the
policy
of president biden towards cuba and the
policy
of former president obama towards cuba
is the approach the same of those two
presidents of
president biden currently and the former
president president
obama so i'm going to be really clear
here so since day one
we have said many times many many times
that the cuban americans are the best
ambassadors
for freedom and prosperity in cuba
that's what i said at the beginning
today the president is going to sit down
and to meet with cuban americans
and leaders at the white house that's
what he's going to do in just a few
hours to discuss
the demonstrations and the
administration's response
and so including applying new sanctions
on cuba on cuban leaders and
establishing internet access for the
cuban people
so we want to lift up the cuban people
and that is going to be our focus
on july 22nd the treasury the treasury's
office of foreign assistance
control sanctioned one of the cuban
individuals and one
cuban entity for serious human rights
abuses
and the repression of peaceful
pro-democratic
protests in cuba that began on july 11.
so we
are going to continue to lift up uh the
cuban american people
that i'm sorry the cuban people and
we're going to have a conversation as i
just mentioned the president will have
one today
and we'll probably have more to read out
from that good
good good jane just really quickly
following up on
someone's question on the eviction
moratorium you said that you've been
working with
congress for some time now is there
anything you can share
in terms of who you've been talking with
and when that started because
democratic leaders quite frankly seem
pretty surprised that it's now their
responsibility obviously we
we know the supreme court decision has
been out for a month
um so so what can you share in terms of
i don't have specific meetings or
conversations to share
look i what i want to be make really
clear is that we are going to con
we're going to work with congress on to
get this done because we understand
the importance of the eviction
moratorium to everyday people
especially after what we have seen this
past year with colgate 19. that is a
priority
for us and we work with congress on so
many different issues and have so many
different conversations and this is
going to be
a priority and so we support what speech
paper losses
is trying to do now do you have any
response to congresswoman ocasio-cortez
calling your handling of the situation
reckless and irresponsible because you
the white house hasn't shown leadership
i i i disagree with the congresswoman
because
as i stated and i've laid out from day
one we have been working
on the emergency uh rental assistance we
have been
uh making sure working with local local
governments to get those funds out
just last month we saw 1.5 billion
dollars in just one month
in rental assistance that which was more
than the
the last five months so we have been
working very hard in a whole of
government approach
that we do here uh at this at this white
house in this administration
and we'll continue to do that thank you
back to senator cinema's comments which
she noted her reservations about the
price tag
do white house negotiators and the
president support
senate democrats scaling back the
reconciliation deal
well this is a process that we're going
through this is a negotiation process
we're going to continue to have to
engage congressional members
on the hill when it comes to
reconciliation
and also clearly the bipartisan
infrastructure deal
so we're we're not going to i'm not
going to stand here
and trying to negotiate from the podium
i'm going to let
congressional members do that we'll work
closely with them
we understand this how incredibly
critical this is this is part of the
has she clarified if she'll negotiate
things from the podium
economic policy for this country and he
is
all in on this he brought people here
right to work with both sides of the
aisles
to bring this bipartisan deal on the uh
on the heart infrastructure and we're
going to continue
as well with the whole build back better
plan back to covet i know you said it's
up to the cdc and health officials to
lead on new recommendations
but has the white house or the president
asked them to look
at new restrictions possible
restrictions surrounding
large group gatherings given the delta
variant transmission
again we follow the science and we
listen to public health officials
that's how we we move forward with this
science
administration earlier this week laid
out their plan on addressing root causes
in central america
including combating corruption in the
region
it comes days after guatemala's special
prosecutor against impunity
was fired um the state department had
suspended cooperation with guatemala's
attorney general so
i guess how does this affect the white
house's work in the region
and does this cause any setbacks thank
you for the question yes
this is something that we are very aware
of um
so um
the the situation in guadalajara look
it's important to us
to make sure that um you know
that uh that uh that corruption
um is um as we're dealing with the
northern triangle
is dealt with where is her page guys on
this
i wanted to share with all of you i can
find it
really quickly just give me a second
gotta reorganize the binder i don't have
it with me
um but it's something that we're aware
of and um as you can imagine as we're
dealing
with the northern triangles as you just
stated it's in critical and important
that
when we're dealing with these countries
um and talking about how we're going to
help them with the root causes
that uh corruption um you know is not
is is is um is is something that doesn't
affect the process that we're trying to
make
and you know when we when we do deal
with the northern triangle countries
it's not giving money directly to the
government it's working as well with
uh the organizations on the ground so
that is also inc
critical and important and so we're
going to keep an eye on that we're going
to stay focused on that as well
and we should have more to share on on
the guatemala situation
oh my gosh i totally forgot
then he went donald trump oh my goodness
give me one second
oh man fresh vegetables
our fun friday one of the wettest we've
ever seen hey
for our last question for our fun friday
zoom reporter
uh hailing from black information
network
uh vanessa vanessa hey vanessa tyler how
are you
hi green thank you so much for taking my
i cannot hear you
can you hear me let's hope like the
repeating echo happens
can you hear me hello i know
there are pets questions in the room for
sure
oh no sam cetera
hello understand the question how do you
test when
we don't test it do we listen to public
health and scientists and they tell us
that it's the delta variant
oh
i mean that's what they are telling us i
laid out why
i laid out how contagious it was and i
laid out why
uh why we needed to act on the delta
variant i laid out
a lot of what the answers we get is
because they say so without a lot
well they're the experts it's not is
that newsmax or something these are
scientists these are experts
i just said that hold on one second i
hold on one second i just said that dr
lewinsky
said just she's saying lewinsky
career she had never seen a a variant
that was so contagious
so this is 20 years of her career so
this is
absolutely absolutely a
major major problem that we are trying
to deal with that's why we heard from
the president yesterday
that's why we keep talking about people
need to get vaccinated
so that is that is the that is the way
that we're trying to move in this
administration making sure
that we are protecting uh people here
making sure that we're dealing with this
pandemic
in a way that is effective and that's
how we're going to move forward i'll
take another question
oh my god
in april um the chief of staff told
playbook that the education department
was reviewing whether the president
could forgive student debt and that
review would be done in a matter of
weeks right a matter
um so uh this is the student the student
student
so the president is signing away ten
thousand fifty thousand which is a week
so i think we've been you know the
president as you know supports uh
congress providing ten thousand in
student relief and debt relief
and he continues to look into what the
debt relief actions can
be taken administratively i don't have
an update on that
at all right now at this moment look the
department of education is working in
partnership with colleagues
at the department of justice and white
house to review options with respect
to debt cancellation and so again i
don't i don't have any updates
okay we're gonna have to wrap up yeah
we're gonna have to wrap
up guys we're gonna have to wrap up
thank you so much is the video woman
gonna ask a question or what
thank you everybody
can we hear you now
we're trying to hear you and we cannot
vanessa i
do you want to write a note let us know
what your questions
is all right all right vanessa we'll try
next friday
okay okay
all right guys vanessa we'll see
we'll try and do it next week oh man
isn't that the best
what a mess what a tech disaster
um you know what would be useful if
someone can get me
that reminds me there's clips that would
be good for my sound board
the two or three times where trump had
audio feedback during those rallies
before the election
um and then like criticize the audio
engineers
i think that that would be um those
would be really good if somebody can get
those to me
all right thank you everybody we'll have
some streams in the very early days of
august then i'll be away for a little
bit then i'll be back
uh it's just all going to be oh can you
guys not hear me oh that's too bad
that's that's a shame um no thank you
everybody for joining me they were only
about an hour and 10 minutes late
but we got it done and i'll see you soon